Hello the Internet!
🎵 I'm Gav, 🎵
🎵 I'm Dan 🎵
🎵 We're the Slow-Mo Guys 🎵
🎵 Gonna make a big mess 🎵
🎵 Looking really Badass 🎵
🎵 I'm Gav, 🎵
🎵 I'm Dan 🎵
🎵 Gonna make a big mess 🎵
🎵 Make the biggest mess we've ever made, 🎵
🎵 Yes! 🎵
🎵 We are, yeah 🎵
🎵 Gonna make a:
Mess! 🎵
🎵 We are, Yeah 🎵
🎵 Looking really Badass! 🎵
🎵 Gonna make a: Mess! 🎵
🎵 Gonna make a: Mess! 🎵 (2x)
🎵🎵🎵 YES! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵Now Dan is ready to leap 🎵
🎵 Onto to the Trampoline, 🎵
🎵 Frantic, And full of Adrenaline 🎵
🎵 We had a couple of Calamities 🎵
🎵 Flipping twatted me! 🎵
🎵  How did my life find me in this Situation? *Sigh* 🎵
🎵 With a Condom on my head... 🎵
🎵 And a Lung full of Cinnamon.. 🎵
🎵My Fate is sealed, 🎵
🎵 There's nothing I can do... 🎵
🎵 Nothing I can do... 🎵
🎵 It was at this point that he knew... 🎵
🎵 That he knew 🎵
🎵 I do not think this is a good idea. 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 AT ALL! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵  Don't think there could be a Jankier table. 🎵
🎵 Could you see? 🎵
🎵 Not really.. 🎵
🎵 Could you breathe? 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 NO! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵🎵 I'm ready! 🎵🎵
🎵 You ready? 🎵
🎵🎵🎵🎵 I'M READY! 🎵🎵🎵🎵
🎵🎵🎵 GO!! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵 WOOOOOO!!! 🎵
🎵 (WHOAA!) 🎵
🎵 We're all heroes in Slow-Mo! 🎵
🎵 (SLOW MO!) 🎵
🎵 That is one of the greatest things, 🎵
🎵 Ever shown! 🎵
🎵 We're all heroes in Slow-Mo! 🎵
🎵 SLOW-MO! 🎵
*Rewind*
🎵 I'm Gav, 🎵
🎵 I'm Dan 🎵
🎵 We're The Slow-Mo Guys 🎵
🎵 It's a Six-Foot Balloon, 🎵
🎵 Dan's Inside, 🎵
🎵 I looked Online 🎵
🎵 Saw: "Climb in Ballon" 🎵
🎵 Like: "It is time" 🎵
🎵 "It is time" 🎵
🎵 "it is time" 🎵 (2x)
🎵🎵 "IT IS TIME" 🎵🎵
🎵 Gonna climb into the balloon 🎵
🎵 Gonna climb in 🎵
🎵 Like a Human sized womb 🎵
🎵 Like a human WOMB. 🎵
🎵 It's nice and Refreshing! 🎵
🎵 Got loads of room! 🎵
🎵 It's nice and Refreshing! (2x) 🎵
🎵 In the 6-Foot Ballon! 🎵
🎵 One of the funniest things I've ever seen! 🎵
🎵🎵 Like a Slug with knees! 🎵🎵
🎵🎵 Like a weird Genie! 🎵🎵
🎵 Got an itch on my Head, 🎵
🎵 Can you get it please? 🎵
🎵 I wonder if you could drown.. 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 EASILY?? 🎵🎵🎵
🎵 25 Airbags wired up with paint 🎵
🎵  What are the chances of these, 🎵
🎵 Going off in your Hand? 🎵
🎵 Trying to decide 🎵
🎵 Where we're gonna stand 🎵
🎵🎵 Ready??? 🎵🎵
🎵 3... 🎵
🎵 2... 🎵
🎵 1... 🎵
🎵 GO! 🎵
🎵 WOOOOOO!!! 🎵
🎵 (WHOAA!) 🎵
🎵 That's how you make a Raaiinbow! 🎵
🎵 That looks massive! (Massive!) 🎵
🎵 That was the Coolest, 🎵
🎵 Coolest, 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 RAINBOW!!! 🎵🎵🎵
*Smash*
🎵 It lasts forever in: 🎵
🎵🎵 SLOW-MO! 🎵🎵
🎵 (Slooow-mo!) 🎵
*Auto-Tuned Laughter*
🎵 Good Lord! 🎵
🎵 Goodness Me! 🎵
🎵 I'm doing the hero pose. 🎵
🎵 That was the Coolest, 🎵
🎵 Coolest, 🎵
🎵 RAINBOW! 🎵
*Smash*
🎵 We're all heroes in 🎵
🎵 SLOW-MO! 🎵
🎵 SLOOOW-MOOoo.. 🎵
🎵 Flip! (1x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (2x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (3x) 🎵
🎵 flip. (4x) 🎵
🎵 Goodness Me! 🎵
🎵 Flip! (5x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (6x) 🎵
🎵 flip. (7x) 🎵
🎵 I can't breathe! 🎵
🎵 Flip! (8x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (9x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (10x) 🎵
🎵 FLIP! (11x) 🎵
🎵 Flip! (12x) 🎵
🎵 Good Lord that was gross 🎵
🎵 But we love it! 🎵
🎵 We love all kinds of Slow-Mos! 🎵
🎵 (GO!) 🎵
🎵 WOOOOOO!!! 🎵
🎵 (WHOAA!) 🎵
🎵 That's how you make a Raaiinbow! 🎵
🎵 That looks massive! (Massive!) 🎵
🎵 That was the Coolest, 🎵
🎵 Coolest, 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 RAINBOW!!! 🎵🎵🎵
*Boom*
🎵 It lasts forever in: 🎵
🎵 SLOW-MO! 🎵
🎵 (SLOW-MO!) 🎵
*Auto-Tuned Laughter*
🎵 Good Lord! 🎵
🎵 Goodness me! 🎵
🎵 I'm doing the heeero Pose 🎵
🎵 Wicked! 🎵
🎵 That was the Coolest, 🎵
🎵 Coolest, 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 RAINBOW! 🎵🎵🎵
*SMASHY!*
🎵 We're all heroes in: 🎵
🎵 SLOW-MO! 🎵
🎵 (GO!) 🎵
🎵🎵 WOOOOOOOOO!!!! 🎵🎵
🎵 I can't believe how much was in your mouth! 🎵
🎵 It's never ending! 🎵
🎵 Visually... 🎵
🎵 That was the most delicious things... 🎵
🎵 Wait! 🎵
🎵 Where did the Goggles go??? 🎵
🎵 I WAS TOO EXCITED! 🎵
🎵 YOU'RE A MANIAC! 🎵
🎵 I just sort of closed my Eyes 🎵
🎵 And Hoooped.. 🎵
*Auto tuned laughter*
🎵 Flip! (13x) 🎵
🎵 Oh my God! 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 WHOOOOAAA!!! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵 I'm doing the heeeero pose. 🎵
🎵 Goodness Me! 🎵
🎵 That was the coolest, 🎵
🎵 Coolest, 🎵
🎵🎵🎵 RAINBOW!!! 🎵🎵🎵
🎵 We're all heroes in: 🎵
🎵 Slow-mo! 🎵
🎵 Slooooow-Mo! 🎵
*Bam*
🎵 (Slow-Mo!) 🎵
🎵 Sloooow-M000OOOoooo...
[End Song] [Outro time!]
Well that was different.
For sure.
*Chuckle*
I mean it's about time we got a new channel trailer, to be fair.
It's true. The old one was about three years old, needed modernizing.
We've officially been songified by the Gregory Brothers
We've now officially had a slow-mo Schmoyoho Collaboration.
That is a mouthful. I'm glad you had to say that, not me, to be fair.
Yeah
Well if you fancy listening to that in your own time and your own six foot balloon outside, like I do
you can find it in a link down here somewhere in the description
Yeah,
iTunes link below and go subscribe to schmoyoho
And us if this is the first video you've seen from us.
Be sure to watch all the videos that you saw in that remix mashup flip.
Flip. Goodness me.
And I promise you that will be the last time we ever sing on this channel.
I've never sounded that good before.
- Me neither
Imagine if this is the first video someone sees of us
Be a bit weird, wouldn't it?
- Yeah
Oh you should also we do slow-mo stuff as well by the way
yeah, mainly
- yeah, mainly slow-mo stuff
We will resume regular content in the next video. Thanks for watching